so when we looked in the last video my
security overview for particular website
we noticed he actually wasn't using
Tiffany Hellman it was using elliptic
curve diffie-hellman so this is just
going to be a short video but explained
broadly the difference between the two
without going into too much maths
although actually the massive elliptic
curves isn't that difficult
let's not go over too few he'll win a
third time so you and me have some kind
of secret key and we use that to talk
securely diffie-hellman is how we get
that secret key every time I talk about
diffie-hellman and use any kind of
analogy people were like oh sure it's
the math so this is for the math people
we had a few interesting questions on
the diffie-hellman video so let's
explore remember about Alice here has
some public variable G ^ a mod n now
what's important about this is that in
some sense a has been mixed into this
generator so what we can't split it up
she can send this around without
everyone working out what a is which is
the important thing so really what the
mathematics behind diffie-hellman does
is allow the protocol to send messages
where you can't extract this private
variable and that's exactly what
elliptic curves do they just do it in a
slightly different way I'll draw a
picture elliptic curve ish right so this
is an elliptic curve elliptic curves are
curves in two dimensions we need colors
on this mark colors couple colors it's
the future right so if we formula for
elliptic curve is y squared is X cubed
plus ax plus B and that's the last time
we were to talk about it so the
parameters of the curve or a and B and
then the curve will look something like
hold on I'm going to sort take a bit of
artistic license with this but something
a bit like that
now they vary in shape depending what a
and B are the thing about elliptic curve
is in our motion arithmetic we had
numbers going around modulo n right
which is just a list of numbers it's a
cycle of numbers here we have a cycle of
point somewhere on this curve so our
generator will be a point on this curve
let's listen use blue shall we this is
our generator that's a not a good place
for my generator it's not a good place
my generator because then my next
example of adding things to the
generator won't work let's let's do it
let's do it there all right ignore that
point that can be a different point for
later now if this is our generator G
what we can do instead of raising things
to powers we just add G to itself we
have 2 G 3G 3G is G Plus G Plus G
yeah so what we can do is we can add g2
itself to do that what you do is you
draw a line at the tangent of this curve
all the way until it hits another point
on the curve you flip it over to the
other dimension and this is 2g over here
3G would be the line between these two
find out where it intersects and flip it
over here so this is 3G 3G plus G would
be it goes along here like this
intersects the curve somewhere else
flips over and it's over here so this is
4G now we won't look at it anymore right
the actual formula for this is just
mathematics to do with lines and the
tangent of this curve it's actually all
very complicated the point is what we're
doing is by multiplying G by various
numbers or adding it to itself this
point addition we're moving around this
curve sort of seemingly at random
right a bit like how we were moving
around our clock face seemingly at
random so the nice thing is that if
you're adding points together one
elliptic curve you will always intersect
only one other point which means that
you've never got a choice of two or
three points where you could go so that
helps a lot when you're doing this so if
I give you a point on the curve here and
I say question mark G right how many
multiples of G is that then any ideas
no no idea at all right it could be 50 G
it could be 5 billion G we don't we you
know it there's no way of knowing that
is our private number and that's the
thing we can't extract back out here we
couldn't get our a if I give you a G
that's all I'm gonna capitalize it now G
Plus G Plus G Plus G a times on this
curve I give you that point and ask you
to tell me what the private variable was
oh no idea you know for a small curve
you might get it off a few attempts for
a big curve you're never going to get it
oh it's going to take you so long and
you won't bother
so what elliptic curves do is literally
a plug in replacement for the
mathematics that a modular arithmetic
mathematics involved in normal
difficulty late B G and their shared
secret will end up being a B G and it's
very very similar now just to give you
someone we also do this all modulo n
because why wouldn't you know because
that's how the mathematics works
that's what
we do so in fact it doesn't really look
like a curve anymore I'll show you a
picture of one so this is an example of
elliptic curve I just looked on internet
right modulo something like 460 this is
some curve I don't know what the
parameters are now you can see if this
was a generator the points are just
gonna dot around all over the place
eventually they'll go back to the start
and cycle background again but not for a
long long time so if I give you this
point and tell you what was my private
number that's how it's secure it's very
hard to undo that and in fact it's very
mathematically quite easy to calculate
some multiple of G and move around but
it's difficult to undo that process
that's the private part of elliptic
curves you know I'm going to ask you
though why why would you bother with
this so this looks like it's are being
unnecessary complication yeah well it's
a notice in some sense slightly more
complicated but actually mathematically
it's much more efficient the so elliptic
curves are a little bit harder to solve
this elliptic curve discrete logarithm
problem which is what we call it it's
slightly harder to solve in some sense
than the regular discrete logarithm
problem which means that elliptic curves
can get away with shorter key sizes and
that just means less computation when
you're calculating a to the G or B to
the G to give you an example so let's
imagine that I use a different key was
three thousand bits long I would get the
same security from an elliptic curve
where my prime n is only 256 bits long
which is much much shorter the matter is
much easier to compute much much faster
so there was a strong tendency to use
elliptic curves for that reason if
you've got to imagine if you're a server
performing these key exchanges all the
time because people come into your shop
or something like this then that kind of
savings actually quite useful it doesn't
really matter if you're doing on your
home PC but you know that many you might
as well use it with the flip side of
that question that yeah is anyone still
using the other way yep so there are a
few people who are a little bit
suspicious of elliptic curves and
certain elliptic curves for example the
NIST P 256 curve has its disk trap
detractors because they're not
absolutely sure where things like this a
and B came from and so on okay maybe I
mean for what it's worth big companies
are also using that curve and they seem
to be fond of it other curves are
available to give you an example I've
used a publicly available cryptography
library to generate a couple
essentially equivalent to G to the a and
a G just so you can see the difference
in this sort of size we're talking about
here if I run this Python script we've
established a generator and a large
prime and this prime is 2048 bits so
this is our a and this is our G to the a
mod N and you can see I mean this will
be slightly shorter but the idea you can
see they're there they're quite long
approaching two thousand bits so that on
a fast version you can see it didn't
take very long to compute but it took a
little time to compute if I've run the
same thing using elliptic curve
cryptography on the NIST P 256 curve
we'll see it should be a lot shorter
okay there we go right much shorter the
missing 256 bit number much much shorter
you can see our private key is actually
a number because it's a number a the
number of times we've jumped around our
elliptic curve and this is our actual XY
coordinate of our point on the curve so
you can see it's split into here's the
first part and then the second part here
so this is X and this is y what you
would normally do in this kind of
situation if you were driving a key from
this is scrap the Y and just use the X
because it's long enough and secure
enough but that will depend on your
situation there are debates that I had
over what curves are safe to use a lot
of people use the NIST PT five six curve
but some people other researchers don't
think that secure because it may be made
they've taken shortcuts on some of the
parameters for efficiency reasons
they're not sure where somebody's
parameters came from and that isn't
without precedent there was a situation
where an elliptic curve random number
generator was found to essentially have
a backdoor which might be for a
different video so the x.25 five one
nine curve is quite well-regarded
because they've gone to great lengths to
demonstrate how they came up with their
variables and why it's used you know if
you're if you're intricate to graphic
research this is something that comes
concern you who's just using the web
probably don't worry about it heed the
message hello computer file pop up so
it's getting the data of various things
and we see here hello computer file
we've been able to do this by accessing
a value that we shouldn't be able to
access this code this if statement
should stop us being able to access this
past the end of this array